James can you try and take us through a
journey let's imagine that we're it
there's a Epcot at Disneyland or
whatever it might be and we're gonna go
on a little roller coaster I'm gonna sit
in the roller coaster and this is social
justice from beginning until now am I
gonna sit in there so where are we where
are we going first was the roller
coaster take us first Hell's Kitchen New
York City early 1900s or late 1800s with
a guy named I mean so the term I think
originated in the 1820s or 40s but I
don't know exactly what it referred to I
haven't gone that far back I'm not going
to talk about Marx although Marx is
gonna be very influential I'm gonna try
to direct it to a number of streams but
the word social justice gained a lot of
its relevance actually with a Baptist
minister engine named Walter
Rauschenbusch who invented what was
called social gospel and if you go back
and read the social gospel it looks a
lot like the social justice of today and
we're gonna leave that as a seed except
that Roush and Boucher ended up working
with people in on your side of the pond
he came over to London and got in
cahoots with the Fabian Society early on
which is a far-left
organization eventually spawned the
London School of Economics which is a
socialist School of Economics and so on
think-tank now and so he came back to
Hell's Kitchen he's so social justice
started to become a thing within a
within the Baptist religion of all
things which is very conservative now
which is kind of funny so turns out
rostrum boost was Richard Rorty who's
one of the American post modern
philosophers Rauschenbusch was his
grandfather so that's kind of like track
number one then I want to take you to
Frankfurt and buy Frankfurt I actually
mean Frankfurt kind of in mostly New
York City because the Frankfurt School
was mostly in New York City because of
the Nazis so they had to leave Germany
because that's when that was going on it
started in the late 20s and so not
long later most of them relocated to New
York City so you're talking about Max
Horkheimer Theodor Adorno Herbert
markussi eventually a decade later two
decades later Jurgen Habermas Walter
Benjamin was early on allegedly Adorno's
stole most of Benjamin's ideas and so
these guys laid as we talked at the
beginning of the conversation they laid
the groundwork for this critical theory
idea and they ended up especially coming
off of Mark oosa the groundwork for what
became known as the social movement
known as a new left and the new left is
what was responsible for all of the when
you talk about the crazy politics of the
1960s and all of the riots especially
around 1968 the new left was really what
was responsible for that so these guys
vision for how society should be
organized and ultimately viewed through
critical theory in order to overthrow
the hidden oppressions and justices of
liberalism and Western civilization
became a huge like political movement on
the far left it defined the radical left
so all your radical feminists your black
power movement you know Malcolm X etc
all of that would have had in some sense
either direct or indirect ties to the
thinking of the new left and so that
kind of whole far left radical activist
morass which was actually quite violent
at the time in the 60s that you know you
got the may 1968 what was in France and
Paris you got whatever happened in the
u.s. some of the riots got pretty
intense Berkeley and so on and so that
would be kind of like the second stop on
our little roller coaster is that
philosophy there so especially like I
said Mark kusa who was extremely
influential with these these kids he I
actually saw an interview with him from
the 70s where he was a bit dismayed with
how people were taking up his ideas and
being uncaring kind of roughshod and
wild with them I was gonna say so that
we can we can kind of have a would you
say one of those dips takes like a PhD
level dipstick of the intent
of how much this is becoming malignant
because you know we hear these things
we've got Malcolm X we've got these are
just in most people's eyes there's some
extreme tactics that are being used but
they're just causes there's a few people
that were there I can see these and say
that shouldn't have happened so where
does this try to sort of lose its way as
well so yeah we'll get there so I want
to actually dip back to Paris for a
minute because around that same time
around the 60s and early 70s is when you
had the post modernists really coming to
bear now the context in Europe more
broadly of course also was the collapse
of colonialism at this point so you had
the post-colonial people really starting
to speak out about how bad empire was
and the damage that that did and it's
kind of set now it became very actually
central to European New Left thinking
where as at roughly the same time in the
u.s. it started shifting toward anti
Vietnam War sentiment and so they kind
of had two different paths going on
there so the post modernists arose in
the European context of being French and
highly influenced by some of the German
idealist s-- philosophers and so they
they were at the Sorbonne that I think
the University of Paris in Paris anyway
and they all kind of work together and
study together and you have this kind of
whole little group of you know Derrida
Foucault et cetera they didn't always
agree sometimes they didn't like each
other sometimes they did but there was a
sort of occasionally Marxist
occasionally Leninist occasionally
Maoist occasionally not that
occasionally communists occasionally
anti-communist but very far left there
is no stable knowledge we got because
the post-colonial context we have to
look at different cultures
there's no way to compare a culture
we've been doing that that was unjust we
were saying Western cultures better so
they had to cut back from the pull back
from all of that kind of thing very
culturally relative we can't really
obtain an objective truth we think that
the West is so good but it made World
War two
you know all this death and destruction
it came up with the Atlantic slave trade
became an interesting topic
all of these horrors that came out of
Western culture so we can't keep saying
it's so good and postmodern theory was
born and so I think postmodern theory
was actually not really it was it was an
offshoot of and not really in line with
the rest of what the so called New Left
was doing and then so where did it
really start there are already problems
here but where it really started to
become malignant was when those two
things came back together and that would
have been in the mid in late 1980s so
through the 70s and 80s for example
within feminism you would overwhelmingly
have had radical feminists and Marxist
feminists or they're called materialist
feminine feminists being the ones doing
the analysis and they would say oh well
women were a commodity under patriarchy
and patriarchy and capitalism are in
cahoots and so the patriarchal
capitalist system is what needs to be
overthrown and so you can kind of see
this is a very radical mindset you had
people like Andrea Dworkin and all of
these characters Catherine MacKinnon who
were very against pornography as a form
of exploitation of violence against
women a lot of this dipped in and out of
the liberal feminist stuff but the
radicals were separate and more often
separatist and in intense and their
their their approach this of course is
also by the way all along stimulating a
backlash from the Conservatives who are
afraid that this is the end of society
and the making so you know something's
boiling on the other side as a result of
this that's kind of important eventually
in the late 1980s you had a fusion of
postmodern methods into this radical
left thought and that's where I think it
really started to become malignant
that's where again we talked about
briefly before the introduction of the
intention to do identity politics
through postmodern methods was
introduced
that's where post modernism and
liberalism work simultaneously critiqued
heavily by these theorists but the
conclusion was that post-modernism was
just the
the problems with post-modernism
postmodern myth has most the right ideas
except that it was formulated by white
Western well-off men who could afford to
deconstruct everything and so when you
look at oppression you can't deconstruct
that experience you can't deconstruct
that injustice
hence the turn toward identity
centrality so you had that whole twist
toward let's do identity politics and
let's do it with postmodern methods if
you really wanted to stick a date stamp
on it I would tell you it was 1989 is
when that happened but really anywhere
from 1984 up through 1994 is one that
was developing and cooking and all of
the biggest pieces and most of the
groundwork was laid and from there it's
just actually kind of concretize most of
this happening in the United States
now once the post-modernism was picked
up by these American philosophers so
like kimberlé crenshaw is a legal
scholar Judith Butler as a I guess a
philosopher or something but the queer
theorist is the best way to describe her
now as it's certainly picked up by all
these Americans it just took off I'm not
entirely sure why it took off so heavily
in the American Academy whereas it was
kind of poo pooed and France and France
where it was originated nobody in the
continent or in England was particularly
interested and it just took off in the
u.s. and then of course our academics
exported it to yours and especially to
Australian ones who were also very
interested in these kinds of things the
first Women's Studies department
actually was in Sydney in Australia
which that would have been more of the
radical line so that's how it started to
change and what it changed into by 2010
and anybody who's interested will be
able to read this in great detail in the
book I wrote with Helen which is due out
in May called cynical theories by 2010
or so it had become just the phrase that
is probably best used as it's hard to
say this and have it be understood it's
known knowns things that are known to be
known things that people just therefore
accept as being
generally true so all of the postmodern
theorizing all of the the attempts to
reify certain points around identity
that went into the identity politics
turn in the late 80s and early 90s and
then the developments that proceeded in
the next decade or so everybody just
started taking those things for granted
well that's true everybody knows that we
have decades of theory saying that
that's true there's no reason to say no
that that can't be right we have so much
scholarship now all saying that that's
true and so I 2010 they just started
kind of mixing everything together and
and this sort of super intersectional
framework where solidarity and a lie
ship became kind of core ideas that had
to be paid full attention to all the
time and it started coming out of the
academies and into society then when
they speak about it now it used to be
this crazy highfalutin jargon that
nobody understood complicated sentences
now it's quite clear it's almost
religious in its quality it's if you
could listen to for example Robyn
D'Angelo is the famous whiteness scholar
it sounds very much like a woman talking
to children with her theory it's
comprehensible by a ten-year-old very
straightforward very clear very
self-assured absolutely confident in the
underlying assumptions that these
systems of power are the correct way to
view the world and the identity is at
the core of systems of power and
knowledge and who can have what in
society and do what in society so that's
sort of like the broad tour of how this
all has come down largely because it
tends to eat itself also it tends to
concentrate you know and get more and
more virulent anybody who kind of says
well maybe it's a little bit not quite
that extreme is that person's gonna get
shut down big time so this is this is
slowly this is a really interesting
point that came up in my discussion with
Douglas Murray and with other people as
well which is that it needs discussion
zinc as we increasingly sort of
polarized
opinions about any topic the room for
muons and I suppose this loops to how to
have impossible conversations which is
your most recent book the room for
nuance and subtlety is is largely
missing and the problem is that to your
own side if you're in this quite sort of
militant discussion where you're
supposed to be as aggressive or or as
convincing as possible to your own side
nuance and subtlety
sounds like a lack of commitment to the
cause and to the other side
nuance and subtlety sounds like a lack
of conviction or a potential weak point
in your argument do you think that's
fair so yeah yeah I think that's right
and there's been a little while ago I
was giving you the tour and I said that
all along each step along the way the
new left the riots in 1968 the turn
toward identity politics et cetera and
then more recently all the things where
it's become you know widely disseminated
I left out that this happened mostly in
where it got the tightest hold was in
education or schools of education have
basically been social justice oriented
since the 1980s which is becoming a
problem critical pedagogy is what it's
called and it's been more or less the
only approach not even the dominant
approach the only approach to education
so if it's an education
I read that for example in colleges
areas a call this was coming from the
colleges what I read was that the
universities actually experienced it as
a student-led change where did the
students get it from their previous
education which was critically oriented
because our colleges of education have
been doing critical pedagogy since the
80s so all along though I said that this
right-wing backlash brewing well guess
what the far left side of this
interprets the far right side of this as
proof that their theories are correct
that society really is corrupt and
society really is trying to protect
vested interests in the so-called status
quo and the powerful people really are
pushing back against them and they of
course are gonna have your irrational
back lashes meanwhile they double down
because of the exact dynamic you just
said nuance can't be allowed because it
looks like a lack of commitment or
betrayal and from the other side it
looks like you know a weak point and so
both sides have actually pulled apart
from one another is seeing the other as
as I Helen and I wrote an article in
2017 that we titled this dynamic
existential polarization where both
sides now actually believes if the other
side gets any power whatsoever it's an
existential threat either to the planet
or to our way of life or to our civil
our civilizations or societies or
something like this and so that's
absolutely non-negotiable nuance can't
possibly exist in such a situation it's
no longer a threat to just your side
it's a threat to everybody even the
people who aren't involved and who don't
know it and they're a threat to
themselves as well right right and so
critical theory of course stems out of
this idea that generally the unwashed
masses don't know what's good for them
that was more or less at Antonio Graham
she's underlying idea that was what you
saw a lot of the motivation on the
Frankfurt School was that if you leave
the masses to choose things for
themselves they won't choose art and
poetry they'll choose football and beer
and go into the strip club or whatever
it happens to be and so people tend not
to choose what's best for themselves and
they need some kind of philosopher-king
to be able to choose for them the post
modernists in particular
Bulger yard and leotard were
particularly concerned with this so
baudrillard especially was that people
never pick art and poetry they're always
gonna pick some low culture trash if you
let them make their own choices so they
clearly don't know how to make good
decisions and everything's artificial
and everything's fake now so which is
also you can kinda say that kind of like
out gaming or that increasing sort of
caricature ISM of what's going on you
know if you were to look at something 20
years ago and say oh you think that
that's vacuous like justjust just wait
until you see what happens when
Instagram arrives just wait until you
see Aaron's when the Kardashians get on
t
be like you know we are able to outdo
ourselves even in how hollow we are
which is yeah yeah just impressed it's
yeah well the left sees the the the
right well I should say I guess that the
the left that's all into this like kind
of high-minded thing that doesn't trust
the masses sees the right is choosing
against their own interests so the right
as background you know the right
conservatives all backed corporate
interests and they you know big politics
and a bunch of white men in a room and
smoking jackets or whatever the hell is
the things are right and so the average
conservative is backing something that's
against his own interests and he just
has to be informed and brought back
around to the right side of thinking and
then he wouldn't choose conservatives
anymore whereas the Conservatives are
like the Liberals are trying to do some
damn social engineering program they
call it the liberal agenda and if we do
that society is gonna collapse and you
can actually sit back for like two
seconds and look at the dynamic and
think man we're [ __ ]
how does that stop yeah yeah I mean yeah
I kinda I think what's going on so
cheers something
[Music]
you